- Hello, thank you for joining us
for this special live
session of Science News now,
on what it's like for journalists
to cover the biggest story of our lives,
the Coronavirus Pandemic.
We'll be talking about the challenges
of covering this huge story
while also living through it
and we'll be answering audience questions.
So please ask them in
the Q&A chat section.
I'm thrilled to introduce you
to the six amazing
Science News journalists
who have led our coverage of the pandemic.
I'll let them introduce themselves.
Aimee, let's start with you.
- Hi, I'm Aimee Cunningham,
I cover health and biomedicine.
I've written about kids and
COVID and COVID vaccines
among other stories, and the past year,
I just finished a large project
that takes a historical look
at infectious diseases and
epidemics over the past century.
- I'm Erin Garcia de Jesus,
I am a staff writer here
and I have mainly been
covering viral variants,
I have a background in
evolutionary virology,
so I've been writing a lot
about the virus' evolution
as well as vaccines and how
virus variants and vaccines
are interacting.
- I'm John Lambert,
I'm also a staff writer
here at Science News
and I focus more on the public
health side of the pandemic.
So early on I was covering
a lot about testing
and contact tracing, and
these days I've been focused
a lot on vaccine equity,
both in the US and abroad.
- Hi, I'm Laura Sanders,
the neuroscience reporter at Science News.
I've been focusing on the
brain and how the virus
might or might not
affect the brain directly
and how stress from the
pandemic has interfered
with all sorts of things.
I've also covered how
shutdowns and school closures
affected kids, both mental
health and academic performance.
- Hi, I'm Sujata Gupta
I'm the social sciences writer
and I've covered a range of things
involving people's psychology
and mental health, behavior,
risk perception, along with disparities,
social and educational level disparities.
- Hi, I'm Tina Hesman Saey
I'm one of the senior
writers here at Science News,
my bead is molecular biology,
but the past two years I've been covering
mainly many aspects of COVID,
including drug treatments, vaccines,
how the virus affects the body
and lots of other little things like that.
- Thank you all.
Let's start with Erin and
talking about the big news
of this week, you just reported
on the new Omicron variant
in our coronavirus update newsletter
and also for our website.
And what has it been like
covering the emergence
of these new variant, especially
when, at the beginning,
there's almost no information available.
- I mean, in short,
it has been much like the
rest of this pandemic,
which is to say it is a rollercoaster
specifically with Omicron,
I think many of the unknowns
are very much still unknown.
For instance, when I was reporting
on things like the Alpha
variant that at first emerged
in the United Kingdom
at the end of last year
or the Beta variant,
there were some indication
already in the community of
increased transmissibility.
There is some indication that Omicron
may be more transmissible,
but a lot of that data
is very, very early, so
I would say the unknowns
are even greater in this case.
So we're navigating this
very hard to navigate time,
and it's very hard to report on things
that we don't have answers for
because people want answers.
I want to know all the
answers to these questions,
our readers want to know,
the scientists themselves want to know,
but we just don't have the data yet.
So trying to take a step back
thinking about why we
don't have answers yet,
what will it take to get
answers, has been an interesting
experience, and difficult, I would say.
- Really difficult that
uncertainty and frustration
and just not knowing feels
a lot like it did way back
in January 2020 at the very
beginning of the pandemic.
There was just so much we didn't know.
John, you wrote our very first story
on the novel, "Coronavirus,"
in early January,
what were you thinking about that then?
- Yeah, that week,
so I think I published
the story on January 10th
and that week, my head was
not in the world of virology,
I was working on this story
about ocean acidification,
whether it was affecting fish behavior
and we get this WHO report
that there's this outbreak
of a mysterious pneumonia
like illness in Wuhan.
And I was assigned it not out
of any particular expertise
in virology or epidemics.
And I remember just trying
to call up a few sources
and try to get a handle on
what this was and what it meant
and going back reading the
story now is kind of surreal.
I have it up here and I just want to read
the first two sentences, 'cause
I think it's kind of crazy
to think how little we knew.
But on January 10th in 2020,
I wrote, "a mysterious
outbreak of pneumonia
in Central China has
preliminarily been pegged
to a new coronavirus, but
the world health organization
says there's no need to panic.
Chinese officials have
reported little evidence so far
of human to human transmission,
but WHO says, making an
epidemic less likely."
Which in hindsight seems kind of crazy
but that was our take
back in early January,
but sort of sum up, I
wasn't really thinking
that it would explode into what has
when I first started
reporting on it back then.
- What's the one piece of
evidence or thing you heard
that made you realize, oh
gosh, could be really bad.
- Yeah, I think as sort
of the weeks progressed
and the sources I was talking to
went from being sort of very careful
not to overstate the risk,
to being a little more
sort of audibly worried,
my general sense of
worry, sort of crept up
and then there was actually
a study that Tina flagged
about a German business
meeting, where it became clear
that people could spread
the virus before symptoms.
So Tina was the person who
made me think, oh gosh,
this is something we'll
probably be having to deal with
for quite a while.
- Righty, yeah, that study out of Germany
was at this German auto-parts company
where they really jumped on things
and that outbreak at that
company told us so many things
about the virus.
That was like the thing
for me that really made it
seem like a big deal
and that this thing was
going to go crazy
because they did find
evidence of transmission
before people had symptoms,
and in a follow-up
to that initial paper,
they like actually tracked
the people and they isolated
infectious virus from them
and they found that even people
who never developed symptoms
could transmit the virus
or at least they were
making infectious viruses.
And then a little later
at the beginning of April,
the National Academies of
Sciences released a report
saying that the coronavirus is airborne,
that it could be transmitted
in aerosol droplets
that you're out just
sitting there breathing
or quietly talking and
then you make many more
after that, so those two
things together were like,
oh wow, this could be bad.
- Yeah, oh, wow, indeed.
And Laura, you were actually
at scientific meetings
with thousands of other scientists,
what was that like?
- Yeah, I mean, looking back,
I would never have guessed
what would have happened next,
but it was very much a moment
that I'll never forget.
I was in a session on
the coronavirus, 8:00 am,
on Valentine's Day with
my editor Macon Morehouse
and we were listening to
Trevor Bedford at the Hutch
and scientists from Data Foundation,
talk about how much we
don't know about the virus
and how our estimates at
the time were likely to be
vast under estimates of how many people
had already been infected
even back in February.
And so, yeah, just that
feeling of sitting in a room
with a lot of other people
inside in a big conference
and there was a sense of kind
of anxiety and fear, really.
It was the first time
that it really hit home
with what we're facing,
what we're looking at.
So yeah, that's a moment I
won't forget from this pandemic.
- Yeah, it's not often when we're sitting
covering a scientific meeting
where the dominant emotion
is fear, that's for sure.
We have an audience question.
How do you handle stories
where the information
you're learning today means
that a story that was written
only a few months ago is now inaccurate?
I think that ones that we saw a lot of
because, especially in the early months,
there was so much science
coming out so fast
and things were changing so fast.
So who wants to talk about
how we as journalists
answer that?
- Well, I think we try to
acknowledge what the state
of the knowledge was before
and what the scientists
have now done in order to figure out
what is really the case
or at least what is our
best understanding now.
And communicating that
uncertainty is really important
and it's a very difficult job.
I think we need to let people in
on what exactly the scientific process is
that it builds on itself,
it corrects itself
and just because the state
of the knowledge changes
doesn't mean that, that
means we have to throw out
everything and can't trust anything,
over time you get a more
concrete understanding
of the thing and once you
build up a certain level
of evidence, you can be pretty
confident in the answer,
but, you know, sometimes mistakes are made
and I remember at the very
beginning before we knew
that this was an airborne virus,
people thought that it was
transmitted mainly by droplets,
that you would spew out
and then touch a surface
and touch your face and
then get infected that way.
And they were saying don't wear masks
and so one of my husband's coworkers,
his wife called me and
was like, I bought masks,
now people are saying
we shouldn't wear masks,
but they're saying we need
them for the hospital workers.
But if they protect the hospital workers,
why won't they protect me?
And I thought, you know what,
that's a really good question
and I don't know what to tell you.
And I still regret from the
very beginning saying that,
very beginning saying that
ordinary people shouldn't wear
masks because it's very clear
that masks work in our
one layer of protection
against the virus, and you
just have to own any mistakes
and like I said, acknowledge
what the state of the knowledge
was before and try to move on.
- Thanks Tina, yeah.
Again, this has been
such a difficult subject
for us to cover in so many ways.
Actually, here's another audience question
that is a good one for us.
This listener says he's a print journalist
and he's very impressed with
the academic credentials
of the journalist who
write for Science News
and many of you have a PhD
and other advanced degrees
and how does that
academic knowledge change
change how you approach your assignments?
- I mean, I think for me
it doesn't always affect
how I approach assignments,
I do sometimes have to
kind of remove myself
from what I know just on a regular basis
to think about what our
readers need to know,
because my background is in virology
and my background is in immunology
and I write a lot about
both of those topics
and so sometimes I have to
remember that something that
that is buried in my brain,
that I know as something
that I think lots of people
will know, like T-cells are important,
not everybody knows what a T-cell is.
These are cells that are in
our body that are on the hunt
for pathogens that are going to protect us
and they're really
important for protecting us
from disease. So taking a step back
and thinking about what
information is 100% relevant
to what story I'm writing
and what do our readers,
what questions are our
readers going to have,
is really important.
- Thank you, Erin, that's really helpful,
especially for people like
me who do not have PhDs
in virology.
So I want to ask Aimee a question,
especially since she
covered a lot of how COVID
has impacted children,
including how they get sick
with COVID, what might happen,
and also how it's affected
schools and learning
and how is reporting on that
shaped your perception of
how this is affecting people?
- Yeah, so, going back
to what Tina was saying,
our understanding of this
virus continues to change
over the course of the pandemic.
And as a reporter, we're
taking in all that information
and we're continually trying
to make a bigger picture,
but often the public just gets snapshots
and I think it's been, it
can be difficult to dislodge
early impressions that people get,
before more data has come in
and before we have gotten
to get that better picture
and this has been really
true with kids in COVID.
So, early on, there were
fewer cases for kids
compared with adults and it wasn't clear
if kids can really spread COVID
and that's in contrast to,
we know kids are really
good spreaders of influenza,
but that was a time when
kids weren't in school
and that was a time when
kids weren't in the community
like they normally are.
So there's a lot of nuance
there and there's a lot more
we had to learn.
But I think early on
this idea that got stuck
in people's heads that, oh,
kids aren't affected by this
and that's a comforting thing,
it's understandable why
people heard that and like,
okay, good, we're set with that.
But, we found that wasn't the case.
As kids got back to
school, as kids got back
to their activities, to their sports,
as they were out and about,
especially as the Delta Variant hit,
cases in kids went up and with that
came more hospitalizations and
with that came more deaths.
And we have learned about
really severe immune response
that kids can have at
least after infection.
We've learned, kids can have long COVID.
So I think it's really
challenging as a reporter,
all the information coming in
and you're trying to
create this bigger picture
that captures a nuance
and tries to help people
understand, this is what we
understood in the beginning,
but this is where things are now.
And that's for many
things about the pandemic,
that has been a challenge to get out.
- Thank you Aimee.
We have a listener who wants to know about
what process we use to verify
stories before we print them
and also, what we'll use as resources.
And that's actually something
we've talked a lot about
with this because we ended
up using a lot of sources
that we typically don't rely on,
we're pretty much obsessed
with accuracy here
at Science News, and we fact check,
we have professional fact checkers,
we do a lot of verification
and a very careful about our sources,
but this up ended our
processes in a lot of ways.
Tina, you had some thoughts on that,
do you want to weigh in?
- Yeah, definitely.
I've been reporting a
lot on vaccines and drugs
and a lot of the first
information about those
comes from press releases
from the companies
that are making them.
And so you have very little data to go on,
you have only the numbers
that they give you
and they don't tell you much as a whole,
sometimes they don't even tell
you exactly how many people
were in the trial, for instance.
So you have to report that,
you put a link to the
source and then you talk
to other experts and try to see,
does this sound reasonable?
What are the caveats here?
And that's also been true for pre-prints.
So, prior to this, we rarely
would report on pre-prints,
which are papers that are
posted to these internet servers
for anybody to look at and comment on
that have not been through
the peer review process
that is normal before papers
appear in scientific journals,
where other experts in the
field have come through the data
and seen whether this
is a reasonable thing.
Peer review has lots of
papers that get retracted
even after they've gone
through peer review,
but at least it's one layer of
vetting of a scientific study
that you don't have when it's a pre-print.
So you have to be really
diligent about going
and getting outside
comment and getting people
who really do know what's
going on in that field
to take a look at it
and try to help you out,
tell you where there are
shortcomings and things like that.
Yeah, we do a lot of fact checking,
trying to find independent
sources to verify these things,
it's really not easy,
especially when there's so
much information coming out
and so much of it being contradictory.
You don't really know
exactly what is right
at the beginning, and like I said earlier,
sometimes it's maybe better
to wait a little while
to try and figure out what's really true
and what's not by the
weight of the evidence
that's coming in.
- Yeah, I just wanted to
add something to that,
Tina mentioned that we're relying a lot
on pre-prints, which we are,
but we also have to
remember that sometimes
even peer reviewed papers,
we really need to get a lot of
perspective on those as well,
because peer review is not perfect
and so getting a lot of,
talking to a lot of scientists
or talking to a lot of
experts in that field
to get a sense of even
peer reviewed papers
is really important.
I remember the first
coronavirus story that I wrote
was a few weeks after John wrote his
and it was a peer reviewed paper
that said that the
origin of the coronavirus
was in snakes.
And all the virologists
that I knew were like,
this is ridiculous, no,
and I knew as a virologist,
that it was probably also not true.
So I talked to a few experts
and who told me the analysis
that was in this paper is not appropriate
for the type of conclusions
that they're trying to come to,
so, I'm taking this with a very,
with a grain of salt, this
is probably not the case.
And it ultimately, it
definitely was not the case.
It was an interesting
experience and I mean,
that being my first story was,
taking down a peer reviewed
paper was interesting.
- Good story.
- Yeah, if can add to,
I think Science News has
provided a good resource
in this media environment
where often headlines
will sort of grab something really catchy
from an individual study,
but when you delve into
the details of that study,
it doesn't really support the headline,
that's getting sort of blasted
across a lot of large outlets.
One example that I remember was in,
it was in August of 2020,
or sometime around then,
there was a study that
caused headlines to say that
neck gaiters were worse
than wearing no mask at all
because they like sheared the droplets
as they were coming out of your mouth.
And a lot of people wear
neck gaiters as masks.
And so I looked into the
details of that paper
and it was in no way designed
to answer that question.
And I think that we provided
a good kind of check
on this story that had gotten,
or this paper that had
gotten sort of undue coverage
by just delving into the
details of that paper
and saying what they can and can't say.
- Yeah, I particularly appreciated
your work on that, John,
because it is pain-taking
reporting and it's also tough
to come back when all these
other news outlets are saying,
oh yeah, neck gaiters are
bad and say, well, no,
actually, what the study says is this,
and make sure that people
get the accurate information.
We have a number of listeners
who are curious about COVID
in the brain and I'd love to
hear from Laura and Sujata
because you have put a great deal of work
looking at COVID's effects on the brain,
on mental health, and
also on how people behave.
Laura, do you want to start out?
- Yeah, sure.
It's, been fascinating
and like all these other
aspects of the pandemic,
the science has been really unsettled
and there's still a lot
more questions than answers.
The kind of best evidence
so far suggests that
coronavirus doesn't affect,
infect brain cells directly,
but it's more, kind of
these systemic effects
of being severely ill.
But one thing that's
definitely clear is the stress
and worry and anxiety
that this has all caused,
has huge effects.
And it's been interesting
because that's not a new area
of neuroscience.
For a long time, people have known that
severe long unpredictable
stress can really do a number
on all sorts of things, our
thinking abilities, our sleep,
our mental health.
So we've been kind of following
along and trying to put
what we're all experiencing
into this context
of this research that we know.
So it's been interesting thinking about,
the features of the pandemic, such as,
we're all isolated at home,
we're all wondering what's
going to happen next,
it feels like a
rollercoaster as Erin said,
and out of burdens of
homeschooling children
or extra job duties, it's all
kind of this perfect storm
of if you were to design
a system to create
kind of damaging stress
responses, this would be it.
So, I mean, that's the pessimistic answer.
I think John might have more optimistic,
what can we do about it?
How do we go from here?
- Well, I'll start with pessimism,
but maybe I can end it optimism.
So I remember when I was first studying
sort of the mental health
fallout of the pandemic,
there had been no book for it
and on how we would handle pandemics.
And there was this expectation
that people would behave
in a certain way,
basically they would follow
whatever advice is given,
but the advice was, as Tina said,
kind of contradictory, like around masks,
and then also just people
didn't behave in ways
that people had predicted.
And so covering behavior has
been a very interesting journey
through this whole thing.
I just remember early on, I covered,
I spoke to a scientist
who talks about risk perception a lot
and she just had this excellent point that
we know that people who feel more angry,
are going to flout the rules more, I think
and people who feel more fearful
are going to sort of hunker down more
and that turned out to be so prescient,
I think in the end.
And I think personally I
was getting a little down,
like we were getting this,
overall I would say
we've gotten the science
of our understanding of this
virus pretty, pretty solid,
like we kind of know how it
operates and we keep trying
to keep up with all these variants,
but we haven't really done a good job
on the softer sciences,
I guess, on the behavior
and the decision-making
and the risk analysis,
like that's been a lot muddier.
And so at some point I
think I just took a turn
to psychology and like,
what can psychology say
about how we can handle all this noise?
And I sort of, it was a strange route.
Like, I was like, well, I
remember how it happened.
And so reading about
Aristotle for some reason
And he has these sort of two ideas,
like people pursue a good
life through happiness
and, these are lay
terms, or through meaning
and I knew that people
weren't really happy
and then I'd also read a paper
that said that we get meaning
sort of through our routines
and those were really disrupted
and I'm like, oh great,
so we're not going to have a good life.
And then I came across a body of work
that really just spoke to me
and it was like novel experiences alone,
not adding up to anything greater,
just doing new things could maybe help us
sort of survive this moment.
And so I started applying these things
to my own personal
life, I took up pottery,
which I read about in one of my stories
and I started walking
regularly with a friend.
Initially, it felt so stupid,
we'd go to the same place on the same day
and we'd go on the same
exact walk and like months
into this, I'm like, wow,
this is really an anchor point in my life.
So yeah, I don't know, for me,
that was like a more
optimistic turn that like,
we can do these things
that can make our lives
a little bit better, they're small,
they may not be like
sustainable for like a good life
for the long haul,
but hopefully this is not
going to last forever.
So that's kind of where
I came away with that.
And Laura and Sujata,
you had a really interesting conversation
as part of our session
that was recorded on stress
in the brain and pandemic,
where you talked to
both the neuroscientist
and also a psychiatrist who
works with a lot of populations
in different countries,
people who have been in very stressful,
traumatic situations.
And I loved looking at
that both in terms of brain
and society and how we're
still a part of our communities
and that communities can actually help us
through these horrible times.
What did you learn from that conversation?
- Yeah, I mean,
it gets to this idea of
we're social creatures,
we derive so much of our
meaning in our health
and our success and happiness
from those around us
and being a part of the community.
So there have been really well
known effects of isolation,
in human beings and in animal studies,
we're not meant to be
alone, we need stimulation,
we need other people around us.
And so I think that
discussion and that framework
of us as a part of a larger
system is really helpful
and interesting, both in terms
of kind of how things go wrong,
but also how we can use it
to buoy ourselves, to support each other
and to heal a little bit.
- Yeah, just to add to that.
Oops, sorry.
- No, go ahead.
- I was just going to say
that I found, Brandon Kohrt
was the researcher I spoke with,
and I had read a popular science article
where he talked about PTSD
and his research really showed
that we tend to treat PTSD
or post-traumatic stress disorder
as a sort of individual problem
manageable with sort of
wellness programs or yoga
or mindfulness, which
not to knock any of that,
but his research really showed that
it's a societal problem
that when people returning from war
have a societal support group,
they actually fare a lot
better than if they're left
on their own other wellness programs.
And I thought that was really eye opening
and just really spoke to how
intentional we need to be
in this moment where it's
easy to be super distant,
that we need to continue to
cultivate our communities
or build new communities and
actively seek out community
as one of the most important things
for our overall wellbeing.
- It's so true and I also
loved how your researchers
talked about empathy as
being incredibly powerful,
not just receiving empathy,
which you said, yeah,
that'll make them feel better,
but also having empathy for
other people and making yourself
feel better too.
One thing that I think
has been hard for us all,
everyone around the world, but
also for us as journalists,
is being stuck at home,
working from our houses
and apartments, and as
journalists we love to be out
in the world and reporting
on what's happening.
And John, you had the opportunity
to do some field recording
this summer, on getting vaccines out
to underserved communities.
What was that experience
like after being at home
for so long?
- Yeah, it was really energizing.
So I had been kind of
thinking about doing a story
on vaccine access around that time,
in late spring and early summer.
The sort of sense that I
got was that in general,
people kind of thought that like the US
was a wash in vaccines
and if you weren't vaccinated,
that was sort of on you.
When in fact a lot of communities
faced a number of
different kinds of barriers
in getting access.
And I was interested in
exploring that question
and a statistic from a
Kaiser Family Foundation Poll
popped out to me from that time,
which found that Hispanic adults
were more than twice as likely
or about twice as likely
to express a strong
desire to get the vaccine,
but they hadn't yet gotten
it than other groups.
And so I started doing some
digging to try to figure out
why that might be the case, and ended up
talking to a couple of
medical professionals
who sort of started this entity
called Unidos Contra COVID
to try to bring vaccines
to people where they were
in different Hispanic
communities around Philadelphia.
And I talked to two people
involved on the phone
and they were really great conversations.
This small team was
working sort of overtime
on a volunteer basis for the most part,
trying to get vaccines
to these communities
and setting up sort of pop-up events
at different community events,
where they could meet people
who often aren't sort of
going out of their way
to get medical care, a lot of people in,
or some people in these
communities were undocumented
and so they sort of go
from their home to work
to a trusted place of worship
and that's sort of the only
places that they really go
and this group was
trying to bring vaccines
to where those people were.
And I was lucky enough to be able to go
to one of these events and
actually talk to the people
who I had talked to the
phone on, the doctors
and nurses involved in running
these events in person,
and get sort of a better
sense for who they were
and why they were doing
what they were doing.
And also talking to people
who were at that event.
It happened to be for
a community soccer game
where there was live music and taco stands
and other food trucks
and just talking to them
about why they hadn't gotten vaccinated
and why they were getting vaccinated now.
It was really energizing to
just hear from people in person.
And I think it created a better story
because I was able to get
sort of a taste of what that
event was actually like.
- Yeah, that story kind
of inspired me to John,
because it was like, it's never
too late to get vaccinated
and one aspect that you
didn't really touch on here
is that a lot of people
haven't gotten vaccinated
because of misinformation.
And that's been a big theme
also throughout the pandemic,
is just a lot of misinformation
about the virus itself,
about vaccines, about treatments
and so, that's kind of another big part
of what we do as journalists,
is trying to give people
accurate information
and counteract that misinformation
without inadvertently spreading it,
which is kind of a challenge.
- Yeah, we actually got
a great question on that
from a listener who wanted to know,
how does your awareness
that you're speaking
to almost two warring publics,
the COVID vaccine deniers and
the COVID vaccine encouragers,
affect the content and
tone of your report?
And we write for the general public,
how do you write for the public
when you know that people
have vastly different
points of view about this?
- Yeah, some of that is
kind of hard to counteract
because it's a belief system
as opposed to presenting people
with facts and then having
them decide rationally
based on the facts.
But as journalists,
that's kind of what we do
and I recently wrote a
story and a newsletter
that was adapted into a
story for our website,
about misinformation
surrounding infertility
from the vaccine.
I got very frustrated because every time
infertility would come up,
other outlets would say things
like, there's no evidence
that the vaccine causes infertility.
Well, while that's true,
it's not nearly strong enough
because not only is there no evidence
that it causes infertility,
there is plenty of evidence
that it does not cause infertility.
And so I kind of went through
a rundown of various studies
that show that it does
not cause infertility.
It does not cause stillbirths,
it doesn't harm you, but
getting COVID, actually does.
I don't know if that
changes anybody's minds,
but it's what I can do
to be part of a solution
rather than part of the problem
in spreading misinformation.
- Thank you, Tina.
Aimee, I'd like to ask you a question.
You mentioned earlier that you
spent a lot of time this year
looking at epidemics of the past,
as part of our Century of
Science coverage for Centennial.
And you really came to
find that those experiences
that people had, before really
having lessons for us now,
what do you think is important
for people to know about that?
- Yeah, so, in working on this,
for all of the advances that
we've made in our understanding
of pathogens and the immune system
and in the development of vaccines,
which is all truly amazing,
what really struck me as
I looked back at epidemics
over the last century,
going back to the 1918 influenza pandemic,
is what hasn't changed,
it hasn't changed nearly enough.
Epidemics continue to
disproportionately impact
Black people, Latino
people, Indigenous people,
and others due to racial discrimination
and long standing health inequities.
Epidemics can leave many
children parent-less
and evidence shows that
without societal support,
these children face devastating health
and socioeconomic consequences.
Epidemics leave communities grieving
and yet society as a
whole is in a real rush
to put epidemics behind us.
Yeah, in the end, epidemics,
it's not just a story about science,
it's a story about people
and about suffering
and about loss.
And I think we need to
do a much better job
acknowledging that,
acknowledging the grief that's out there,
acknowledging the loss that
people have experienced,
understanding more
about, what does it mean
to live through an epidemic?
What does it mean to
emerge from an epidemic?
What do we need to do to support people
and take care of the lingering,
long lasting physical and mental impacts.
And it's also, really,
we are still the public
health cornerstones
that we rely on with masking,
with social physical distancing,
with closing down large public venues.
We started doing that
a long, long time ago.
These things work for us
and they're really important
parts of our response.
- Thank you, Aimee.
We've got a couple of
questions from listeners
who want to know about,
what it's like to be
living through a crisis
at the same time reporting on it.
And was it a challenge to
step away from the anxiety
which we're facing personally,
to report on this issue?
Who'd like to answer that one?
- I can start, partly, it's
really hard for me to disconnect
from anything that's going on.
I think in part, just because,
even were I not a journalist,
I would still be thinking
about this extensively.
Because of my background,
a lot of the people that I
interact with on a regular basis
are in the virology world,
so even when I'm not at
work, thinking about viruses,
the people that I talk
to in my daily life,
I'm also talking about
viruses or the immune system,
or, my mom is a school
nurse, I'm talking to her
about what's happening in her school.
So I don't often get a break,
but then when I try to
force myself to take a break
or take a step back, I can't.
And especially in my classes,
when I was in grad school,
we hear a lot about,
we would talk a lot about disease X,
we learned about pandemics
that had happened in the past
and what's the future
one going to look like?
And so the realization
that this is a disease X
there will be other ones in the future is,
it's a surreal experience, I think,
to have gone through
the training that I did
and then be living through
this and then reporting on it,
sometimes I feel a little bit dissociated
from everything and I think part of that
is probably a defense mechanism,
so I don't go too far down the path
or I'm trying to protect
my own mental health,
like kind of like Laura
and Sujata alluded to,
they know all of us are struggling.
I don't know how long
it's going to take for me
to really kind of grieve
once all of this is over.
It's one day at a time type thing.
- Yeah, I hear you about that,
Erin, about being always on,
because when I'm not
reporting on stuff actively
and reading all these papers,
and I'm hearing the news and
then I have family members
and friends asking me for information
and then for advice
about what they should do
in their daily lives.
I mean, I have friends on
Facebook who message me,
and one was asking me,
should I get my kid vaccinated right away?
Or should I wait for a while?
And other ones have asked
me various questions,
they asked me to vet things
that they see on Facebook
or in social media, which is good,
I mean, I'm glad that
they're looking to see
whether or not what
they're hearing is true,
but I feel a tremendous
sense of responsibility
to make sure that people have
good, accurate information.
And it can be really hard when
I don't always know what
to do in my own life.
So, how can I possibly tell
someone else what to do?
It's very difficult.
So yeah, it's been a hard row.
- We all know too much
(laughs)
and too little at the same time.
- Right, right?
I mean, and it also intellectually,
the more you learn about it, it's ,
there's interesting things about it
and at the same time,
you're also part of this,
you're part of a pandemic
where people are dying,
people are sick, and you
are trying to maintain
a kind of, I don't know, you never know
when it's going to hit you,
how sad this whole thing is, right?
You're trying to do your
work and you're trying
to put information together
and then something can just strike you
about how devastating this has been.
- Yeah, I would say for me is something,
I love it when people ask me questions
because that energizes me,
like when I'm talking to other people
and people are asking me
opinions about vaccines
or asking me, okay, this
new variant has come,
like, what do we know about
how well vaccines work?
I love being able to
say our immune systems
are really good at what they do,
we can trust in our immune system.
And we can believe that
things are going to be okay
at the end of the day.
But at the same time, then when I sit down
and I have to write the story, I just,
I feel the weight of everything
that I'm going to put on the page
and that people are going to read that.
And sometimes it's a little bit,
I freeze because like,
I don't know how to put
what I just told somebody out
loud into words on the page.
That's a weird experience.
- Yeah, and as the editor,
my job is to make it possible
for these wonderful
journalists to do their jobs
and when it's a story like this,
which is such an important
story and the information
that we're dealing with, depending on it
actually could save lives,
it could harm people,
there is that huge,
I wish I could say to all
of these wonderful people
it's okay, fine, go take a long vacation
and then enjoy yourself.
But I know that they just,
it's, exhausting as it is,
they don't want to give up on the story,
which part of what makes them
as good as what they are,
but it's hard.
And on the other side
of that, the flip side,
we've also talked about what gives us hope
and I noticed that Sujata
talked about her explorations
in finding meaning in life,
both through new scientific research
and also through her pottery,
which I thought was a wonderful
way to combine science
and real life.
What else gives you hope?
John, what gives you hope
in the midst of all this?
- Yeah, all right,
something that has given
me hope in my reporting,
'cause we sort of talked to
and often rely on a
lot of the same sources
and you can kind of get a sense
for how tired they're
getting, as they're scientists
trying to keep figuring this out and
So in my reporting,
I've talked to a lot of local
public health officials,
whether that be like a city official,
who's trying to run public
health programs or school nurses
trying to set up testing
programs for their school
and talking with them, I
always feel a bit more hopeful
knowing that there are these
people who are really working
against incredible challenges
and often amidst a public
who either sort of questions
or outright rejects
what they're trying to
do and sort of the work
that they're doing and, I
mean, it's really hard on them
and yet, a lot of the
public health workers
who I've spoken with over
the course of this pandemic,
just continue to kind of
do their best to build up
a testing program for their school,
or try to find new and creative
ways of reaching people
who haven't yet been vaccinated.
And it gives me a little bit of hope
to know that there are
people out there like that
who are still plugging away
against incredible odds.
- Yeah, it gives me hope to know
that there are these
amazing scientists out there
who are, they're working on vaccines,
they're working on treatments,
they're working to better
understand the virus
and what it does to our bodies,
and how our immune systems
react, and also, just to
see, something we touched on
in the session that Erin and I had earlier
with four COVID scientists,
about how collaborative
people have gotten,
there are these huge
collaborations that have hundreds,
if not thousands of scientists
from all over the world,
putting their brain power
to solve these problems.
And it's amazing how
much they have learned
in such a short time.
It seems like it's never enough of course,
but just the fact that they're on the job,
that's very hopeful for me.
- Yeah, I want to say I kind
of think of it as great,
what I'm grateful for,
I'm grateful for all the doctors
and medical practitioners
who have been caring for
people throughout this,
also starting off with
almost no information
and very little they could
do except provide the care
that you provide for someone who has,
is experiencing the symptoms you know.
And I'm grateful as John was saying,
for all the public health
officials that have been working
so hard, and I'm grateful for vaccines,
that we have something that
can give our immune systems,
a preview of a pathogen,
something that could protect us
from the worst effects, is
incredible and it's not something
that we have for everything,
it's not something we've had
in the past.
It's amazing.
- To expand on that last point Aimee,
it's just, that's also the
thing that gives me hope,
is that the scientists developed
the vaccine so quickly,
thanks to decades of research
that has gone into all of this
well before the pandemic even began.
So, all of that work that they pulled on
to make these vaccines within
a year is just mind boggling.
And sometimes I sit down and I think about
where we might be in the pandemic
if we did not have vaccines
and it would be a very, very
different place right now.
I mean, there's obviously a lot of hurdles
that we're still trying to
overcome, vaccine inequity,
vaccine hesitancy, just
getting vaccines to people
who want them, but can't get them.
I mean, those are big things
that we have to overcome,
but the fact that we even
have them in the first place
to be having those
conversations is incredible.
- Yeah, I was going to add that too,
it didn't have to work out this well,
I'm just so incredibly grateful
and shocked that it worked
this well, that they're
so incredibly effective.
I've had my little daughters
get vaccinated last weekend
and it was just this
moment of extreme gratitude
and more broadly, I
think what gives me hope
is this famous and cheesy Mr. Rogers line
of "look for the helpers,
look for the helpers here"
and that includes those scientists,
that includes all our healthcare workers,
that includes all of
our cafeteria workers,
who've been making meals
for kids who need them,
that includes you guys
covering all of the science
and giving people the information we need.
So, yeah, that's where I am.
- And teachers,
(laughs)
(mumbles) having to come back
in really uncertain environments
as the return to school happened.
- Thank you all, those are
such heartfelt reflections
and I'm looking at one more
comment here from a listener
that says, since we're
celebrating a hundred years
of Science News, I would
be interested to see
a retrospective of how
science and journalists
a hundred years ago covered the last stage
stage of the Spanish flu in 1921.
And I think that's a great question
and you can start by looking
at Aimee's wonderful story
on our Century of Science page,
which is looking at
specific scientific examples
of the past hundred years
and also includes highlights
of our coverage, and you can
also dig into our archives
on our sciencenews.org website,
which has more than 80,000
articles of original coverage,
which you can see exactly
what it looked like
on the page back then.
And this spring, we're
going to also do a history
of our reporting over the years,
which includes some of the
amazing things in science
that we've covered, whether
it's the discovery of the DNA
double helix or insulin or
antibiotics or the Space Race,
but also some places where we went wrong
and science went wrong, too,
and covering things that
turned out to be dangerous
or wrong or unethical.
So I encourage you to stick
with us and look forward,
we've got a lot more coming
as part of our celebration
of our Centennial.
And I am hopeful and grateful
because of our great
journalists and many others
around the country.
We just had someone post a comment saying
how wonderful it was that
people were able to move
from physical to virtual
socialization and work
and do concerts, look, school, play date,
all providing social
interaction in ways online.
That's true, I think at
the time it didn't seem
like it would be nearly the compensation
for not being together,
but I know that all that virtual
communication last winter
really helped me get through this
and I know it did for many others, so.
I would like to say thank you again
to our amazing journalists
and the work they do
and thank you to our great audience
of Science News readers online
and in print for supporting us
and, anybody have a last
comment you want to say
before we sign off?
All right, please stick
with us and see what we do
at our next a hundred
years of science coverage.
Thank you all.